hello and welcome to this video playing
Yvonne year let's key let's key okay
let's see what we get here some italian
game check but rare line and I'd BTW too
hi this is interesting that's an
interesting point sacrifice ah ok I'm
taking it I think this is the best move
but I have no idea how the details on ok
I think this cannot be wrong check it's
probably going T sixer something like
that hmm it's definite compensation for
white some kind of compensation at least
not sure if it is enough but we'll see
happy to return one pawn yeah okay this
is probably enough high quality for wide
is the pawn down but term it's got
active pieces so let's see how to do
that probably like b6 Bishop e7 I always
have to return the pawn there's no way
to keep it really for completing
development
yeah let's threaten meet
so what happens here so loop the eight
maybe
okay well love to get on that long
diagonal for good with this with the
Queen but the queen of five or something
like that I don't know how many many
possible moves
Queenie Force One idea
maybe also f6 like f6 97-2003 it would
be nice okay if i go i have six now what
what do you have yeah maybe quindi cell
maybe just maybe just go squinty 7 i
have f takes d5 actually so that should
win for black
what is he doing here there now cream 2g
for something crazy
okay before I do that let's check
quickly if I have something better even
I guess not I mean I thought I can take
F 2 inches I just wanted to make sure
that if there's something something even
better available so check taking this
okay that take be too he might have rope
to dees Evan hmm rook t8 is also an
interesting move trying to play rugby
too but you cannot take it so maybe yeah
and threatens roped it to
ok
yeah I can still go look at you too if I
want something better here just
continuing to attack or something yeah
i'm not sure that I'm winning this
ending but still let's do it
my ass a hard time to keep his pieces
points them rookie 5 rupee to a 40 k 2
is actually winning the April almost
almost sorry not winning it right away
look see Lucas you foam however as
strong so what about this if I shake it
and then roop to a4 b5 rook a 5 you can
come over there okay
I'm going to over 200 I'm doing why f6
here the good thing is that is king is
absolutely absolutely limited down so
the time for Ivy I'm not sure if I
should go h5 let's do it like this
can go all the way to c8 you can never
take 26 I have Roxy to be too and then
promoting so I will ultimately activate
my king
check
I cannot prevent be to look see one a
promotion white resigns yeah so what do
we have yeah I'm not sure man this isn't
this is a line that night BTW to
sacrifice i'm not sure how it precisely
continues I mean chan i'm pretty sure
that why there's enough compensation
here i'm just not entirely oops it was
wrong i'm not entirely sure how he
should continue something like this 26
yeah looks kind of normal i guess not
sure if he needs to but certainly
certainly playable okay i need to get my
bishop out and this yeah i'm not sure
I'm threatening bishop f3 I mean for
high quality you can take on this earth
so we can take one t7 I guess this
should be some kind of equality don't
think that this is a big deal here I'm
not sure 95s i think is wrong I mean
queen here and this is somewhat wrong I
have this idea and f6 is a threat as
well so if you play some kind of non
move from I go f6 or this one this is
given by the engine yeah I always get
here yeah yeah and after this f 6 i'm
clearly better the engine gives g4s the
best movers eyes as I suspected check I
only wonder if I could have done
something better no I plane engine moves
all the way these things takes sorry
that's a bit quick yeah I was also
thinking about this a 4 and T i wasn't
sure i was thinking yeah maybe i can
play
you're 70 so what a big advantage is
that his King is cut and that I think
probably makes it a wind it's a
different story if there's a point on g2
an h3 for example I can go like here and
here and we see that what happened in
the game I could have played King f7
that was a bit more precise but i think
that wins i'm pretty sure it wins I get
there I get the pawn all the way here
and now i can i can i can go around with
the king as he can never take yeah i can
never take one of the pawns as let's say
he goes here i can i can eat just go up
because if he takes i have that rope on
the second be two rooks in one sorry
rook see one method basically the same
thing that we saw in the game so i get
my king up and g i'm promoting the pawn
there's no way around that SP to hear
this is the strength of the root cutting
off the King on the back rank yeah I
think he probably needed to be a little
bit more precise right after the pawn
sacrifice because um it is really is
just white cannot play for an advantage
of this position because a position is
far too solid for that he can get the
point back certainly but he has to be
precise and round here that it gets gets
tricky i believe the computer by the way
gives this line there's also something
that i saw where I'm and porn up but
white is reasonably active for example
this could be something that maybe white
can draw with with activity on the 7th
rank or so you know that's not very
attractive quite clearly okay well
thanks for watching